foreign
[Music]
our first daily cancellation of the week
revisits a theme that we have become
familiar with in this segment another
video has gone viral of a young person
appears to be gen Z bitterly lamenting
the fact that he's expected to work in
fact he says that this expectation is
sick and twisted quote unquote
here he is
it's sick and twisted that I have to
work just to survive just to live my
life for basic ass Necessities like I
don't want to work until the day I die
just to eat and sleep basic human
Necessities it shouldn't be
controversial
Free Housing free health care shouldn't
be a pipe dream and I know a lot of
people are going to be like oh you
should be doing this or that no like
what if I don't want to be rich what if
I want to achieve
I still have to work till the day I die
just to live just to survive people give
up their entire lives
just to retire at the ripe age of 60
whatever
for what to get paid dirt even then
people destroy their bodies physically
and mentally
just to feed into a capitalistic system
that does not give it about you God
didn't make me the smartest Angel but I
know that needs to change
and I don't want to be told that I'm
ungrateful that
I should be happy to have a job where
it's taking up 40 hours of my week
you know I want to spend time with my
family I want to do that is fulfilling
to me but all that like requires so much
privilege it requires so much wealth and
it's just
messed up
40 hours of my week people are complain
about a 40 hourly job they blow my mind
you know how you know how lucky you are
I know he said I don't I don't be told
that I should be grateful well you
should be grateful you brat you know how
lucky you are if you only work 40 hours
that's it only 40 hours a week that's
all the that's that's all the time
you're working think about that the
amount of work period that you do in a
week is only 40 hours
um that is incredible to me I can't even
like conceive of only doing 40 hours of
work in a week okay so we have again
a young man who appears to be well fed
appears to be living in some kind of
comfortable shelter presumably a house
or an apartment and who is obviously
blessed with any number of luxuries like
a phone internet connection we can
assume copious amounts of hair product
he has all of this and yet doesn't
believe that work should be a
requirement to maintain it it's sick and
twisted that he should have to work just
to live let alone to afford his hair
conditioner now
as I've often said in response to these
kinds of disturbingly common complaints
from his generation about the fact that
you have to work is like
about the fact that you have to breathe
you might as well make a video whining
like you're telling me I have to breathe
every second of the day just to live
exhale inhale exhale inhale all the time
just to live what if I don't want to
breathe what if I want to live at the
bottom of the ocean like a starfish why
should breathing be a requirement this
is sick and twisted
found a certain way you'd be you'd be
kind of right it is unfortunate that we
have to breathe we have to eat we have
to sleep all of these are chores that we
are compelled to complete every day or
in some cases every second of the day
it'd be a lot easier if we didn't have
to do any of that it'd be easier if we
could exist as Immortal indestructible
Supermen who need nothing and want
nothing and can do anything without
expending any any energy at all that
would be nice
but that is not how things are or will
ever be
you can complain about it but those
complaints in 20 cents still won't even
buy you a bottle of water especially
with inflation now our friend with the
hair says that working should not be a
necessity
he says that there should be a universal
housing Universal Health Care we should
be given all the food that we need to
eat
all right so who exactly
is building the houses that we are
living in who is cultivating the food
who's providing the medical care you
could say well the government will do it
but the government is not a genie that
can make things materialize out of thin
air the government can only hire or more
likely conscript other people to build
the homes and harvest the food and so on
what this means is I'm constantly having
to remind the younger generation and my
own generation is that no matter what
happens
no matter what system is in place
someone lots of people have to work in
order to keep all of society afloat and
all of the many mouths including your
own fed
people have to work there is no way
around it our system doesn't demand it
capitalism doesn't demand it life
demands it what you are demanding is not
that you get to drop out of the system
but that you be granted the privilege of
benefiting from it without contributing
to it you want others to work for you in
exchange for you doing nothing
you want slaves is what you want that's
what you want you have all the moral
credibility of a plantation owner in the
1840s you have less moral credibility in
fact because even those plantation
owners personally did more work than
what you're willing to do apparently
so you want to do literally nothing
and have everyone else do everything
but what you can't explain either
morally or economically or logistically
is why any of the rest of us should
submit to that system why should we
agree to that
you know you're sitting there saying
hey I have a proposal um here it is I'll
do nothing at all and you guys will take
care of me and do all the work and in
exchange I will contribute absolutely
nothing of value to the world so you'll
keep me alive and comfortable and you'll
do everything for me and I will do
absolutely nothing to help you or to
make your life any better how's that
sound
well it sounds like the easiest deal in
the world to turn down
it sounds like you're a parasite
and you should be thrown out onto the
street and you should be forced to
contribute to your own Survival or die
that's what should happen
that should happen like this kid not
even a kid a grown adult
today
he should be thrown out I'm assuming
probably these parents probably take
care of them throw them out on the
street and say you're done you this is
for your own good
figure out how to survive
that's what it sounds like that's what
you need sounds like life needs to give
you some shock therapy son sounds like
there are a whole lot of people in your
generation who need the umbilical cords
finally cut it sounds like you've been
living with nothing at stake no skin in
the game no real pressure and you need
some pressure
you need some consequences introduced
into your cozy pointless existence
as we're all aware the left is giving up
common sense and has crazy ideologies
this Lent we're going to combat that
with a solid foundation in faith values
and standing above their hypocrisy with
lent starting on Ash Wednesday February
22nd there is no better time to build a
habit of prayer and meditation to stay
rooted than now pray every single day
leading up to Eastern on Easter on how
low the number one Christian Prayer app
in the U.S and it helps me maintain a
daily prayer routine and it can help you
to all you got to do is download the app
for free at hello.com Matt Walsh you can
set prayer reminders and track your
progress along the way not sure where to
start we'll check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year which is
available on the hollow app for a brief
daily Bible readings and Reflections or
you can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg and
even some world-class athletes as well
with how low you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
you listen all the way to work on a
plane in the morning or at night with
downloadable offline sessions and
customized lengths with anywhere from
one to six UH 60 Minute options stay
rooted in your faith and your values and
make this year your year for spiritual
growth and peace get an exclusive
three-month free trial at hollow.com
Matt Walsh that's hollow.com Matt Walsh
by the way just so you know
the only reason you're able to exist and
survive is such a soft non-contributing
little brat is because of capitalism you
complain that capitalism has made your
life so difficult but in fact perhaps
the greatest indictment on capitalism is
that it has made your life far too easy
capitalism's greatest flaw
is you okay the greatest problem with
capitalism is it has made people like
you possible because prior to our modern
capitalistic age somebody with your
attitude would be dead you would have
died a long time ago if you refuse to
work every day and I mean every day all
day sun up to sundown that's the
situation that most people historically
have faced and even today in most parts
of the world you are working every day
every single day sun up to sundown and
when the Sun goes down you fall asleep
dead tired and then you get up and you
do it all over again and if you tried to
drop out of that system or if you
complained that it was it was too sick
and twisted and you didn't want to
participate in it you either would have
died of starvation
or else the other people in your
community or Village would have banded
together and killed you
or perhaps if you're lucky they merely
would have banished you to the
Wilderness where you could die of
exposure or starvation or get mulled to
death
that would have been your fate in
literally any society except for the one
you're complaining about
a guy like this complaining about
capitalism it's like a billionaire on a
private jet complaining about fossil
fuels and the fact that those two would
agree on nearly every issue is not a
coincidence
the fact that the anti-capitalist Gen Z
tick tocker lines up ideologically with
the billionaire class
is not a coincidence but that's
something to explore another day
instead I'd like to wrap things up with
it with it with a different thought you
know we've talked about Mr hair and uh
you know and and why he cannot have what
he wants
um he cannot he cannot have the sort of
existence that he feels entitled to
but let's let's not allow that to
distract us from a more important point
he can't have what he wants
and also
he shouldn't want what he wants
as a young man you shouldn't want to not
work you shouldn't want to Coast through
life
he says he doesn't want to achieve
anything and in that lack of ambition
and that mentality he is joined
unfortunately by many in his generation
but it is a deeply depraved mentality it
is not natural it is not normal or at
least it shouldn't be
as a young man you should have big
dreams and goals you should have designs
on like Conquering the world you you may
lack wisdom and experience but you
should not lack for ambition I mean
that's the one thing you should not lack
for
that's the one thing you should have in
abundance
it's what generations of young men
before you had even if they had nothing
else they had that
I can remember being in my early 20s I
was impulsive somewhat petulant some
would say I still am on both counts but
I had ambition if someone had offered to
hand me a million dollars when I was
like 22. now I would have taken it
because I'm not crazy but I didn't I
didn't want it to be handed to me I
didn't sit around dreaming of that it
wasn't my dream was not winning the
lottery or earning an inheritance from a
rich relative that I didn't know about I
wanted to earn it myself I wanted to do
it myself so that I could say that I did
it I wanted to scratch and Claw my way
to success
if anything my biggest flaw was that I
turned down help even when I needed it
because I wasn't willing to admit that I
needed it
because I wanted to climb the mountain
myself or fail by myself many young
people through history have been driven
this way it's not when I say this about
myself I'm so special I'm not that's the
point it's totally normal or at least it
should be
to have this insatiable desire to make
something of yourself as a young man is
supposed to be the most normal thing in
the world and that's why
I just look with with revulsion at the
young people who don't have this
ambition the Folly of Youth is supposed
to be an over abundance of ambition you
know fearlessness a propensity to to
take too many risks
to be too wild in the risks that you
take in pursuit of greatness
we're supposed to be giving you lectures
about being patient and taking things
one step at a time and not trying to
conquer the world overnight
even at my still somewhat maybe arguably
somewhat young age of 36 especially now
with six kids I am supposed to be the
conservative and cautious one and I'm
supposed to be saying to guys like Mr
Hare hey settle down be careful be safe
don't overdo it okay you don't have to
conquer the world overnight
instead it's exactly the reverse even
now even now me middle aged and and with
a family of eight to support I am still
far more willing to take risks far more
ambitious and vigorous in pursuit of my
goals than these gen Z Tick Tock whiners
who are younger and have nothing to lose
like you you if you that's why I'm
always saying if you're a young person
you have no family no kids nothing
you can go out and do anything nothing
should be stopping you or holding you
back you can move anywhere you can try
you can try different things you could
take risks there's almost nothing at
stake even if it goes horribly wrong you
end up homeless or something it's not
the worst thing in the world you don't
have any kids you could use scratch and
Claw and find you you live in a car for
a while lots of people have done that
it's not ideal but you can do it
now is the time to do it where's your
energy where's your desire for greatness
how can you be this jaded and lazy
already
well I know the answer
and it's not that the world is so much
harder for young people today I don't
want to hear that yeah it's it's not
that they've been dealt a tougher hand
than anyone else in history was ever
dealt now there are some unique and
profound challenges that young people
today face of course but every
generation has their challenges you
don't have to go back that far in
history to find Generations who face
struggles that none of us could ever
conceive of that's how hard they were
so that's not it I think the answer is
much more banal the fact is that the
digital age phone screens porn video
games social media has acted as a great
mental numbing agent kids aren't
programmed from a young age to seek
stimulation and affirmation uh from
anything but
the little dopamine machines that they
carry around in their pockets the only
success they crave is the kind that can
be measured in likes and shares
they're never alone with their own
thoughts long enough to develop a sort
of Rich inner life where all of those
dreams and Ambitions are supposed to
live and grow
now there may be more to the problem but
there isn't much more to it than that I
don't think there is
we got an entire generation addicted to
phones practically from birth and as a
result we destroyed for many of them any
hope that they that they might become
successful
and well-rounded
as people
and along with that we destroyed
civilization as well but the good news
is
that um
the aliens are just going to vaporize us
anyway so it's all a moot point
in the meantime however Mr Hare is
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of shows move over to members block hope
to see you there and uh if you want to
become a member you can do that using
Code Walsh at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]